hello everyone well all of you are
voting for my next series we have
another interesting game to check out
it's again Kasparov against a celebrity
this time
Kasparov is playing against the Gordon
Matthew Thomas Sumner also known as the
sting now how did the two of them meet
over the board it was in the year 2000
and it was a simultaneous exhibition
organised in Times Square New York now
Kasparov had a little project of his own
he organized the chess tournament I'm
Casper of chess calm and in this
tournament over 600 chess schools
participated it was like the world's
chess championship of chess schools and
this is this simultaneous exhibition is
the final event of this of this big
tournament and in this event funds that
were raised for stings rainforest
Foundation now in this simultaneous
exhibition as it is a simultaneous
exhibition Kasparov didn't only face
sting he faced all of his members all of
the members from his band and here we
have this is a part of a part of an
article I found it was on mtv.com but I
will put a link to the entire article if
you want to read it the article was
published I believe the next day after
the simultaneous exhibition a very cool
Kasparov likely not quaking in his boots
played stink Guiterrez Dominic Miller
keyboardist Jason Rebello
trumpet player Chris Botti and vocalist
Russ Irvin simultaneously so there you
have it
Kasparov against the entire band here
well okay maybe better to leave this
after the video but here we do have a
photo of the two of them playing there
as part of walking around playing the
moves and sting on the left so it's it's
actually a pretty nice photo and I also
did find a very short a very short to
video footage of this on youtube so here
I'll just show you a couple of seconds
there's part of holding a simultaneous
exhibition there sting pondering on his
next move
and I also put a link to this video in
the description below so you can check
it out it it lasts only a minute but you
know so let's see this game Kasparov has
the white pieces as is as is the custom
when one holds a simultaneous exhibition
you have white in all the games and
Kasparov opens with g3 this is the
Hungarian opening we have nice to have
six Bishop to g2 and E 5 d3 Bishop to c5
and here you can see Kasparov develops
his bishop on this nice diagonal then he
played D 3 D 3 will be complementing
efore and then later Kaspar will also
play c4 and this will also control d5
nicely so the pawns on v3 and c4 well
there very nicely complemented the
bishop on g2 so this is a very nice way
to open your game Knight to f3
we have d6 Kasparov castles and stink
castles c4 now Knight to c6 and Knight
to c3
so transposing into the English opening
we have Bishop to g4
h3 Bishop captures on f3 Bishop
characters and Queen to d7 so sting gave
up his bishop pair I he grabbed the
knight on f3 now he plays Queen to d7
he's attacking the h2 reform so Kasparov
simply retreat special back to g2 we
have a 6
Kasparov place III and Bishop to b4 now
by sting and casparo plays Knight to e2
from e2 the night can come to g3
after cars power of pushes g4 and then
from g3 the knight will be able to come
either to f5 or h5 depending depending
on the position you could have played
something like Knight to d5 but this
only leads to an exchange of pieces
white doesn't really gain anything here
so nice to e2 making this Bishop on
before look look right or funny rook a
28 and now a3 Bishop back to c5 and now
Queen to c2
we have rook to e7 sting now prepares to
double rooks and e-file
b4 bishop goes to e7 a7 and now Knight
to c3
we have rook F to e8 now sting does
double up
Bishop to d2 and here we have d5
this was all the way after this point a
Kasparov does control more space and his
is somewhat better but it's it's nothing
decisive here sting should probably play
Knight to d8 prepare c6 and only then
try to execute d5 but for some reason
after this Bishop to b2 sting
immediately played d5 which is obviously
a pawn sacrifice the d5 square is
guarded by the pawn by the knight by the
bishop on g2 so there was no talk of
this was this an oversight or was this
like like a pawn sacrifice by sting
but Kasparov except to the point see
characters on d5 now sting plays Knight
to d8 the move we discussed that should
have been played a move before actually
sacrificing the pawn but okay who knows
he might he might have actually wanted
to play this Kasparov now defends the
pawn he plays efore now we have h6 by
Sting Bishop to e3 offering an exchange
of bishops and although the bishop on a7
was a very strong piece now you
definitely want to exchange pieces here
but here a sting played b6 and you'll
see that well this proof other than
giving up the pawn a couple of moves
sooner this move really takes this
bishop out of the game so this Bishop is
now on a 7 casparo will lock the
position entirely on light squares and
there will be no way for this Bishop to
ever see the light of day but we'll get
to that nice to e2 by Kasparov making
room for Queen to come to c6 of course
if this night ever moves if it doesn't
it's just a weird night Knights the b7
and now g4 and making room for the night
and g3 rook to c8
we have Knights the g3 and now Knight
comes the d6 preventing the knight
Knight from jumping to f5 and
immediately Casper becomes Queen to c6
now he will lock down the entire Queen
side using the the pawns on the lights
worse Queen captures on c6 d captures on
c6 and rook to d8
we have a 4 now preparing b5 Knight
comes the ca to defend attacking the d3
pawn rook F to d1 defending the pawn and
now rook to e6 attacking the c6 pawn but
here as part
in time for everything b5 we have a five
by Sting and now if you look at this
position sting has all of his pawns on
dark squares on the Queen side he has a
dark square bishop there is no way for
this bishop to ever leave leave this
this tomb so brush up to f3 Caspar
prepares Bishop to e2 so he can guard
the the d3 pawn with the Bishop rook eat
a d6 now the rooks are doubled on the D
file and Bishop to e2 guarding the d3
pawn nice - h7 trying to activate his
Knight H for not allowing night to jump
to g5 and knife to e7 Howcast power
plays Knight to f5 we have Knight
captures G captures and f6 now rook to
a3 by Kasparov we have King to h8 with
some ideas of maybe going Rock g8 and
pushing the Jeep on rope to d2 rogue
does come to g8 and now h5 Kasparov
doesn't allow a sting to push the Jeep
on anywhere but he allows nice to g5 so
Knight to g5 we have King to f1 and now
Knight to h3 Kasparov attacks the night
Bishop to g4 forcing it back and here we
have Knight to f4 and this Knight to f4
move gives part of the ideal opportunity
to finally push d4 and get rid of his
backwards pawn now of course you can
never capture and before because if you
capture on before the knight on f4
becomes under attack and here you want
to continue something rope to d8 but
still you're you're down in material
your Bishop is are completely out of the
game
white will win this position eventually
but for some reason again stink played
he captures on d4 giving up an entire
piece here so Bishop captures Kasparov
gladly accepts the piece we have Rock D
to d8 and here comes King to e2 Rock to
g8
Rock G to e8 King to d3 and now rook to
e7 Bishop to d1
rugby to e8 now sting double upon D file
but simply F 3 by Kasparov rock back to
the 8th and here F
Bishop to b3 it was in this position
that steamed sting resigns the game he
doesn't really have any move not only
he's down a piece but if you look at
this bishop he's actually down to pieces
and there's there's really no counter
play here Kasparov plays relatively
simple he will simply play rocky one
Brook d1 a King c4 eliminated the d4
pawn and then breakthrough in the
position and easily win this game but of
course as sting sting was a pretty good
chess player he knew this and he knew
that there was no point in continuing
this game swim Kasparov did defeat all
of them and sting lasted the longest out
of his entire band and it took us part
of around 50 50 minutes to defeat all of
them but like I said I will put a link
to the entire article in the description
below so feel free to check it out and
yeah let's let's not forget about sorry
let's not forget about this these are
the current standings of the vote for my
next series so already 10,000 of you
have voted but I will leave the vote
active up until tomorrow and tomorrow as
of tomorrow afternoon or tomorrow noon I
will start my new series so winning so
far is the 2013 candidates plus Carlsen
versus an and match with 37% then Bobby
Fischer candidates plus match versus
passkey 27% then Capablanca vs. lion
match 22% then Tom Tom memorial 2008
from event rooks perspective 10% and
then stanitsa vs. Lasker 4% so unless
this changes and well only 10,000 of you
have voted so far so it it might yet to
change but if it doesn't tomorrow we are
starting with the 2013 candidates
tournament so I am and this was the game
I do hope you enjoyed it it was Kasparov
versus sting and sting said that he
really enjoys chess he enjoyed chess his
entire life and he's a he's a he he was
old friends with Kasparov at the time
this the simultaneous exhibition was
played and after Kasparov the World
Chess Championship four schools ended it
was actually sting who handed out trophy
stood
winners of every division in that
tournament so yeah I would like to thank
Kelsie Roberts Robert Hume Quist
and Michael Wiley for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I'll see you soon with
another interesting game and like I said
tomorrow we are starting probably with
the 2013 candidates tournament yeah and
one thing I didn't know until I actually
read this article is that sting has six
children and he taught all six of them
to play chess he said that knowing how
to play chess didn't really help him
strategically in life but they are very
young and if they learn it while they're
young he's sure that it will help them
so yeah that's it thank you all and I
will see you soon